[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sean berg
oh
tell me that first one
[Music]
[Applause]
we better be in the shade
oh wow
okay
[Music]
david
i'm just kidding hold up
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here it is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
actually
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
[Music]
did you think
[Music]
thank you
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah you're wrong
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
box
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
jesus yeah
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
good afternoon yale college class of
2021
welcome to the graduates of brantford
[Applause]
morse
pearson
[Applause]
saybrook
and timothy dwight colleges
[Applause]
[Music]
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class who are joining us
virtually today
via live stream we are so excited
to have arrived at this special day in a
few moments
we will begin announcing the graduates
as they process across
uh this stage here in front of me
but before we start our program a few
words about the land
on which today's ceremony is taking
place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations
including mohegan mash and tuck at
pequot
eastern pequot chattercock
golden hill pogoset niantic
and the quinnipiac and other algonquin
speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship
that exists between these peoples and
nations and this land
thank you and please enjoy the program
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from sabra college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when they have been recommended
by the faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these
degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
henry maxwell jacob banner bearer of
saber college
benjamin samuel grobman and megan marie
sardis
the procession marshals of sabre college
john cenado ago
jonathan frederick altman
brooke christina alviar
nicholas anderson mia
arias sang jason
luis arroyo mekhi
bakri mario baroques
luke peter griffith benson
kelsey taylor bowen
sydney jordan bowen
ryan joshua kane
sophia harp sophia hartman caro
brianna m carter
joshua peter chellie
caleb hume clothier
curtis wiley calvit ekaterina
danchenko
nicholas charles dewalt
arthur alastair donald
sarah elizabeth force
[Music]
jacob tobin gluckman
joao angelo gonzalez cardoso
emma rose gray
rohan krishna guram
[Applause]
paulina a holly
[Applause]
[Music]
noah faith heinz
[Applause]
marlena hinkle
[Applause]
anna cisco howard
[Applause]
courtney paige howard
amber roing who
[Applause]
evan grace hughes
chantinew rajesh ja
karen yang
[Music]
harry augustus khan
grace unji kang
trent s kanegider
ben caslos caslo
young kim
emma blue kirby
aaron moss kleiner
adam saul crock
elizabeth ann leonard
[Music]
zhenhau lee
asher joseph lifton
brandon john lopez
owen alexander marks
david leopoldo mccowan
maria rose mckinney
[Music]
catherine cahill molaris
nicholas adam moscoso
william scott mukamal
jesse brian nadel
[Music]
[Applause]
aiden august o'connor
[Applause]
teresa
[Music]
samuel woman preston
skyler ruby regan
antoinette dibble roberts
elise rhianne robinson
anthony steve roras
carlos ulysses rodriguez cortez
justin dillon schneiderman
[Applause]
ryan thomas steele
rafael linder steiner
amanda giselle thomas
[Applause]
allison jane vandenbundt
lara victoria varela kaczynski
michael e vargas
christopher g west
august elliott white
felicia lauren wolkov
alice guanyi wu
bradley yam lee young
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
zhu
[Music]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from timothy dwight college
home of the red lions
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when they have been recommended
by the faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
kangri john sullins the banner bearer of
timothy dwight college
[Music]
lena wy chan and alexander costell
demeglio the procession marshals of
timothy dwight college
[Applause]
etan samuel axe
[Music]
ziad abed ahmed
yes mean lavanya alamdeen shazadah
[Music]
landon matthew allen
summer ali boy
[Music]
rebecca lena amanor
grace morgan bartlett
joshua charles beasley
reza elias bergemann
india shannon shanthi balalad
brittany felicia boyce
alexandra eureka boyd
sarah nicole cameron
deja kaleilani chappelle
marianne rebstock cosgrove
[Music]
mariana costellitos
karina daniela defranco
elizabeth lee dolan
owen beals duke
elias kareem farhat
aaron lee gerardo
shannon caroline guerra
harry andrew hegeman
[Applause]
jacob christian heinich
eleanor ida iskandar
spencer travis johnson
[Applause]
tall joseph
tyler joseph jost
maluk khan
nashanth krishnan
derek amur cole de noe
alessandra larocco
alexander ian latham
ariadne latrue
avi lee
erica vivian lin
christina von lindsey
rashendra mcgunty
anusha mongolic
michaela mapotoringa
jacob reuben paul mezzie
ananth miller murray
angel mora diaz
austin phillips o'toole
ally olson jonathan
michael palacios jacob payne
anna rose polish
anna merrill mcclure rezad
tobah lawrence richcond
camila rivera soto
henry rosas ibada
saul isaac roslar
sophia joy ross
gabriel victor roy
alejandra salazar gonzalez
josh samantha ray
christian levan sampleton
[Music]
sharia singh
[Music]
robert francis garonski
isaac donnelly swift
seatte to delay
antolik tran jayden trevic
ryan bilkun to dipserin
marty may tongue
elias armand johannes voss
emery zellers wallace
rhianne michelle wong
kenneth schube nahom
imam and participating remotely
[Music]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from morris college for the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer on them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
zachary william miller banner bearer
of morris college
lorenzo vasily arvanitas
[Applause]
and ava nicknahad marshalls of morris
college
[Applause]
nicholas ryan abusolov
mustafa amir akhtara
justin oben
micah awudiran
catherine nicole penoir
[Music]
[Applause]
andrew bilido
brigitta my burgess
lucille francis burton
natalie jasmine bosomaker
alexander alexandrovich budavetsky
alana
thomas edward carrillo
nathan alexander chang
allison chen
[Applause]
yun
cronin
maria elena cunningham
anastasia rose dalianes
paige hopkins davis
[Applause]
jonathan william duber
christian reed duvall
[Applause]
joshua mark diaz
faye shattan
[Applause]
haley isabel gibadlo
lillian grace gold
jeremy goldwasser
derek kenneth gautier
julia charlotte guerrari
samuel howard grove
megan lara alexandra gupta
[Applause]
tanisha gupta
[Music]
nora marie heaphy
ariel m shea
colleen margaret huffman
karthik iricom
[Applause]
[Music]
hale gordon jaeger
isabella rose jennings
claire sally kalickmann
isla khan
james curtis large the second
[Music]
jake joseph levin
sandra lee
[Applause]
stephanie marie malta
brian callahan matthews
hannah kami melchinger
catherine claire mourneau
courtney monique nunley
[Applause]
[Music]
chayton anthony povick
nicholas armand patton
dante michael paleco
[Music]
[Applause]
nikhil sunjay patel
samuel timothy piccarek
jordan cunningham perry
[Applause]
j brandon james linton peterson
daniel antonio peta
[Music]
sean william radgowski
benjamin colton rob
ian michael salvamoser
erasmus peter lillios schlitter
[Music]
matthew brian sparrow
[Applause]
zachary carl stanek
[Applause]
armin matthew thomas
adam neil tucker
[Applause]
cameron matthew warfield
nicole marie waters
[Music]
lily weisberg
[Music]
tyler harrison welsh
harry davidson westbrook
leah hannah ciao
daniel dove yadin
[Applause]
alice elizabeth yan
tony zhang
helen zhao
[Applause]
and graduates participating remotely
[Music]
[Music]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from brantford college for
the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you by your official act to
confer
upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer
upon you the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
akil vikram aditya rajen
the banner bearer of brantford college
athena renee flint shall have it
schwartz procession marshals of
brantford college
anissa kim abood
[Applause]
joseph david allen
valentina amate perez
lakshmi rivera i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
isabella marie back
alex jean bernal
gabrielle gene brannon
michael cao
[Applause]
[Music]
wesley day
celia vanessa de leon
[Applause]
david o'conn adimo
rohan garg
louis elijah goldsmith
andrea gordon detzky
aisa janae gindo
[Applause]
theodore jeffrey hague
lauren jessica harris
kieran hassan
grace worthington havilland
james clayton hebert
yeema ho
audrey yinggang
dana norbert joseph
sam katz
unique chion kim
[Music]
lee
kay lee
[Applause]
michael davidson lyndon
[Music]
vivian mayers
lucy mcewen
[Music]
kathy maymon
maxwell tyler modell
[Applause]
jack morton
[Applause]
keaton irving mueller
allison mina park
maya chakrabarti passaic
thomas clark pointer
[Music]
[Applause]
carolina lima porcilla
thomas arthur grant kejano
[Applause]
agasha karif raton
alexander james reedy
jasmine teresa rios
[Applause]
[Music]
william clarence rogers iii
ethan roman ross
[Applause]
george cariakis sabbaticas
[Applause]
andrew scheinberg
[Applause]
[Music]
anna francis smith
[Applause]
v wintron
ah jeremy level eighth
[Music]
i'm glad you came
hannah berma
[Music]
vaudeville ford
[Applause]
melinda wang melinda young wayne thank
you
liesel
hi lenahan vangerman
ethan morgan williams
alvin maurice winston ii
[Music]
[Applause]
alan lee woo
andy dane von hilscheimer
[Applause]
alan lee wu
sorry timothy
dorje wu
wyatt jackson yes
[Applause]
vanessa jahweh john graduates
participating remotely
[Music]
thank you
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from pearson college
for the bachelor's degree in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college and approved by
the corporation
dean chun will ask you by your official
act to confer
upon them these degrees
[Applause]
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me
i shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
the banner bearer of pearson college
royce penn lee and nigel connor wade
the procession marshals of pearson
college
adriana ruby arcia
aishwarya bhattacharya
jonathan bulafin
veronica chen
justin huang chang
brandon nicholas cobb
alexis caroline cook
charlotte grace cooperman
[Music]
quincy montgomery crawford iv
kimberly cruz bustamante
alec die
kimberly dao
[Music]
claire m davidson
[Music]
gregory dimitri dulles
ian akira denzer
victoria l dembrowick
edward n dorobek
rebecca catalina drachmann
alana simone island
matthew luis fantasi
matthew l ferraro
benjamin sol friedman
jonathan patrick frith jr
alexandra christon goldrun
courtney elizabeth greene
ariana lena harrison
frederick howard hanser
oscar hedeen
kristen elizabeth henry
william who
grace jenn
thomas george johnson
emily elizabeth kilfoil
lucas young min kim
lauren elizabeth victoria lee
jaylen everlay leone
lee josephy logan
melissa dai lou
victoria wendy mack
muhammad amir mudoff
katie mallison
orvin frey alvaro mayari
norah c morrow
dan l nguyen
kevin david o'neal
christine marie oberhausen
[Music]
mike howie olgago
adadeji oh palmer
lauren dawn finney
sophie d pollock
sebastian burunji rogunda quaid
lauren ashley quintella
caleb sawyer rhodes
joseph rivaldo
jared brandon rock
ursula lucila rodriguez
bartoloma bartolomeo rondelli
[Applause]
nilam kor
isabelle sophia sans
thomas henry shocked
young min shin
taylor spidori
eliana rose swerdlow
nicholas victor tabio
yang tai
tanner john tavritsky
tyler alexander tavritsky
jason twan thompson
camille ellen um
[Music]
daniel kenneth irkey
milan govinda vivanco
eric yang wang
todd mitchell warshawski
sherry wu
vicki wu
[Music]
vivian zoo
lillian yuan
ahmed zaidi
annie zoe
[Music]
to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents families and friends
looking on
from around the globe
we gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of all of you who have
worked
so hard to complete your programs of
study
we salute your effort your diligence
your talent
and your intellect we also join you
in expressing gratitude for all who have
supported you in these endeavors
your families and friends and teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations class of 2021
hello class of 2021 my name is curtis
calvette and i'm your class treasurer
four years have gone by in the blink of
an eye we've made so many memories
from the first year snowball fight on
old campus to the yale
harvard football game in 2019 where we
won in double overtime
to all the late nights whether they be
in the library studying for an exam or
in the common room
talking with our friends and suitemates
although our senior year experience was
certainly not a traditional one the
class of 2021 made the best
of the situation when we leave yale in
just a few days
we will leave with memories and
friendships that will last
a lifetime here's to the class of 2021.
we did it
[Applause]
congratulations
class of 2021 good afternoon
my name
my name is akhil rajan and i'm a member
of the committee that organized class
day
which will air on youtube tomorrow at 2
30 p.m
two minutes before at 2 28 a special
piece written by class day speaker
robert lopez
will be played from harkness tower so
keep your ears open
and if you haven't already decorated a
funny hat for class day
it's not too late in fact on your seat
today
you received a class of 2021 hat which
you might want to use for that very
purpose
you'll also find a gift bag which
includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions as
well as a few
that are unique to the class of 2021
in addition to the class day speaker
tomorrow's program will also include
remarks by members of our class
who've put together outstanding original
speeches
and because class day is about all of
us you'll see your photographs and video
reflections throughout tomorrow's
program
as well congratulations class of 2021
and see you tomorrow at class day
class of 2021 congratulations again i am
so happy to be with you
and celebrate with you today graduating
is such a great accomplishment
and one of the most important ones in
your life if you think back to when you
first arrived on campus
no one could have imagined that you
would live through a global pandemic
before reaching this moment but you did
and thanks to your strength and
perseverance this moment has finally
come
i am honored to recognize all the work
that you have done to get here
much of it with the support of your
family and friends
today is your day and it is theirs too
today is a day for looking back with
pride at everything you have
accomplished
and all the goals you have reached of
course it brings some sadness too
now that you are ending your bright
college years
but today is a commencement a beginning
so now as you look to the days and years
ahead
think of the new achievements and
opportunities in front of you
and look around as well to remind
yourself
of the excellent company joining you on
this new beginning
your friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back 150 years in
yell college history
i'm excited to watch the virtual program
alongside you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salovey's commencement address
i am grateful to the class day committee
to the senior class council
to to the university secretary's office
to your college heads and deans and to
everyone who contributed to making the
special events
of this weekend possible and i'm most
appreciative to you
for all that you have brought to yale
and now will bring out into the world
with you again class of 2021
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you